freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video heute ist mein geburtstag und ich
dachte mir ich mache einfach mal wieder
video wie ich euch ein bisschen
mitnehmen durch meinen geburtstag in
dieser komischen zeit weil auch
geburtstag haben ist nicht das gleiche
jetzt gerade werden corona ich habe
etwas besonderes überlegt ihr werdet
schon im titel gelesen haben ich mache
später zur feier des tages und cdu
besonders machen weil man nicht feiern
kann oder sonst was ein geisteskranker
steak und ihr werde dabei sein wie ist
es deshalb bleibt auf jeden fall
transport mega cool aber ich dachte mir
essen ist eigentlich so die sache die
man gut machen kann jetzt in diesen
tagen deshalb nehme ich euch jetzt damit
zum frühstück machen ich will es
frühstück machen rührei fresh juice und
zugehörigkeit wir sehen uns gleich
leute hier würden
wir stellen dir auf dem waldboden
das ist so kein bürger mit ruhm
ja
mein erster job 23
übrigens sehr leid dass ich mit meinem
quarantäne frisur umschlagen müsste aber
ich muss das auch nicht mehr alle
zusammen durch kann mir vorstellen es
geht euch allen genau so eine sache nach
dem steak besser wahrscheinlich viele
auf das video geklickt haben lange
darüber nachgedacht ob ich mir jetzt mal
holen sollte so und da wollte ich mir zu
meinem geburtstag denn dann waren wir
gestern beim laden und dann hat
sebastian einfach gesagt komm ich
bezahle dafür also es ist einfach ein
geschenk und ich bin mega gehalt ich
glaube das wird komplett krank eine
komplette krasse erfahrung und ich fühle
mich nicht bereit dafür aber für dieses
frühstück hier fühle ich mich sehr
breiten straßen
zu krass es ist einiges an zeit
vergangen seit dem frühstück langsam
kommt der hunger wieder und kann es
immer noch nicht richtig glauben dass
wir gleich das war glück zu bereiten
ihr müsst wissen was das so besonders
macht erstmal das von der japanischen
rinder sorte die hat eben view heißt und
das besondere eine flasche das ist so
super fein marmoriert es also super g
fett drin hat die haltung von den kühen
ist nicht zu vergleichen mit der haltung
von normalen kühn also die kriegen
teilweise musik vorgespielt und werden
massiert und sonst was ich habe gleich
das krasse privileg das zu essen dass du
probieren ich bin schon super aufgeregt
aber jetzt gleich erstmal wir haben
jetzt 15 43 m 15 findet dass travis
scott vorteil event statt also danke
dass du an meinem geburtstag konzert
spielt das ziehe ich mir noch rein und
danach für richtig halte es ist soweit
das hier ist ein trikot weil man ist ja
nicht weh und wird davon sagt und haben
dazu noch richtig gutes an trikot geholt
das kommt gerade schon auf
raumtemperatur und hier drüben im
kühlschrank könnte sehen ist das vaio
steak das muss nicht einfach so im
kühlschrank leben sondern es bleibt im
kühlschrank liegen aus dem grund dass es
wenn es raumtemperatur hat zerschmilzt
und das ist kein spaß
das fleisch ist so zart das ist wirklich
einfach schnitt also man muss es aus dem
kühlschrank auf dem grill tun war ich
langsam ob ich ob ich würde ich bin
überhaupt und das zu essen
heute sind 100 euro wie man beim metzger
zeit für dieses stück fleisch das heißt
wenn man das in einem restaurant ist
oder so dann bist du mal ganz schnell
bei 300 euro
weil das kriegs auch nicht in jedem
ressort sandkastenfreunde das ist
wirklich eine erfahrung die ich heute
machen darf mit meinem geburtstag und
grimmig jetzt gleich erstmal mit dem
trikot zittrig geil
ich finde es schon was ein bisschen
frech dass man sich dazu zutraut so 100
euro steckt das ist schon krass ja aber
gut man nicht mal wusste sicherlich auch
schon was dazu gesagt aber das ist also
teuer ist noch um so das machst und b
dass sich schon viele mit
auseinandergesetzt hat
das tut mir geschenkt und ich haben
konnte mich gestern nicht bedanken wenn
ich mein geburtstag war dankeschön
corona danke dass der begriff weiter
heißt wir haben hier ist auch so eine
art und weise das zu präsentieren können
ja klar
dieses pack ist schon next level das ist
auch schon das so richtig man weiß jetzt
gesehen habe ich gedacht dass es so dass
zu rot ist das nicht tut ist kein
perfekt essen so perfekt ich fühle mich
- renault george grosz oder wie wird das
bitte gleich das war gewesen dass jetzt
auf die beute dann geht es richtig los
aus dem kühlschrank raus 100 euro raus
auf den grill
das ist jetzt
das war irgendwann habe sie sich für die
rauchentwicklung ist viel größer als bei
den weg dahin war einfach so wie es
perfekt wenn das da unten läuft der
timer damit auch alles perfekt dass
leute jetzt kommt der moment wenn
ständig seite
so was geht dass ich dir gerade ab ich
merke das richtig das ist anders ich
meine es ernst das ist anders sollte ich
merke dass das eine kruste ist die
hierdurch hat es knusprig falls ihr euch
jetzt denkt so her das ist ja noch euro
in drin
das muss genauso gebraten werden weil es
halt eben diese uhr hütet hatten so
unglaublich hoch weiter dies kann man
das vergessen und soll man es auch zu
essen weil das ist eben die besonderheit
wenn man es durchbricht dann verliert
den geschmack ein bisschen mehr salz
ganz bisschen pfeffer
[Musik]
hierdurch sollten
ein alter das ist wirklich anders
das geht so das ist so krass vollmundig
alter da rein und du hast sondern dass
ein holzstock so eine richtige reise und
so geht es hin geht er ist krank alles
probiert
drücken wir denken dass fett christian
brand
mit sondereffekten das fast zu müssen
was griffel das muss nicht die menge
fett haben alles probiert man hier so
bist du auch so eine bubble tiefer bild
war essen und ein ganzer mund plötzlich
voll
ich sag's euch meine daran werde ich
mich lange erinnern
okay das ist wirklich geisteskrank oder
so geil fett durchsetzt dass du das
einfach mal über all diese perfekte ist
schwer zu sagen aber was aber sagt
wahnsinn
auch hier machten die kamera aus und
genießen hatte leute wir sehen uns
gleich ich habe langsam das fleisch
verarbeitet wird höchste zeit für einen
espresso und schießt ihr wisst was ist
das leben so ist das jetzt noch mal
einiges an zeit vergangen ich bin
mittlerweile auch richtig richtig müde
ich habe dann einfach mal gemeinsam mit
meinem guten engen freunden ein bisschen
auch facetime
wir haben alle was getrunken und was
kleines gesteckt was jetzt nicht so ein
gott war das ist ja ich zeigen wollte ja
das war mein geburtstag dieses jahr
wirklich wahnsinn mit dem steak ich habe
so lange noch davon gesprochen ich habe
wirklich gefühlt auch noch eine halbe
stunde oder sogar eine stunde später
einfach dieses fleisch geschmeckt da
wirklich krank war eine krasse erfahrung
und ein schöner geburtstag danke dass
ihr anteil hatte
wir sehen uns im nächsten video wieder
macht's gut